so i've been staying quiet on the whole
joe rogan spotify thing going on and i
don't really want to address that i want
to address just a comment from the ceo
recently where he said what were his
exact words it is important to me that
we don't take on the position of content
censor dude
that ship has already sailed
your platform is
playing host to harmful misinformation
you're not required to host that
purging it is not censorship it's
capitalism
if it's harmful to your business model
you're allowed to expunge it if it is
harmful to the public in general you're
allowed to expunge it if you continue to
host it people are allowed to say we're
not giving you our money none of this is
censorship somebody else will host joe
rogan he's not going anywhere and if
you're worried about all the money you
spent about being able to host this
stuff well we'll be out of pocket for
that tough
you made what turned out to be a bad
investment you lost your shirt suck it
up it happens